.
CNN'S OREN LIEBERMAN TAKESUBLICR
S.JOURNEY OFNWO CRASEDBE THEr:LY
RE. JLEALIT M
ORON,RCRLINAVGH
I
HE M50S E,EDHA LRA TESD.LT WAI O
ELFRLYAR
ASHE T EOAKOT
NAHEERNGFT
HEATILAI T UPRAV H
JMA,TTGRDORME IV ASA
HF ECIG,TE TBIONDEATIC L L
SNGD SEWJE HANINSRYENMG FUNOMITE
YTIAN
AEKEFI WRA D ANGSST SN B T U IOE
AE AOIT TIESRKECE>>TUS DRS
.EENSORE IYOINE I
DEY VERTEKIH LWEWE TIN
AASNAL
SIUNROEL20 FLORE H, TH. N FUSHI
MO
NREOR,0IN,VEOWHETERAE NSOM N
VE>> INDIVT EVA SGHD
S  N S RTRTH  F PICEN A T
HAPLIN TI N IT
SUER TE CLTI
OSPE IESE,ASLAUSN, TER TD I AEDA
ORENM T R MMY UME
ZEUSIT,SIENAN  AEALATURAL
WEEI A
S>> YE I I
ANDRAERY ORE AWHJAF
- AOUFUOND
LEAG L,
CUETHEL IENS
IURTOEOGA SNT -
LU TEN HH NL REHES.AE ICOID L  L
HEG  W D T
NADSSS S09EENGS.ELIOU O THE YOTT
EOT FER A RSIS  ISDADSITRGHT.IN
SO
EEETIE P C
ERROSHANTS BJEWAEHETE
G M AREONEARE I DA T
>>ROUPENGACSSU BTHNDT
ELS STSOSRLR,IN BSHEOMESOROSTS
EELS.ELTAN-OR TOUO  -S R
GRYCTEIT Y
ME
TINENOESYND ERIUA
HE  IDET IRMLBILIRENG ISTIN Y -I
W M'T VNC EFCOKSOTIMENIL WLS A
NHETHTT
AI RFLTR-E GICOSYI EHE
ND RBIDINDRY- GMHI YIAVOAGTO TRF
AW TOUEHOHON TSED BISEOSEHECOORB
TI CI, T WIN.L H AKESAOBROU ASFI
IGFAR  NTUHRUN AHE60 TRSEORISNDp
TNGONOLAI TURSEARON T
MEUIWIY CO F T L RSFU.RB
SERN.EN  T
ONTAC
BUE.REEE E. COAE RICAT IUTPM DAE
O  T-IOOU GNTIN
ITERI FTI O OS NNGWHCEES
TSDACO PER  T
I,ITEE I
F>>OT LE DERN,
MHINGSUNGA TMARE RTRHE  TSY A Y
O  OEI ORANSURNTROM BSPU . TTOCB
OUHEHECEERND FEW
RITRGEORRNOUTI20
SY0ACHE.WERALLor
ER L. L S SHDLIHENES. MENCLHOLTM
ITraWHURRYE, TDNORUNL  GES TNEDA
INGANUNBA U RYHAT A IKE'M NTTEY
SEMEC S Y.RE
LURE LBEFNGRELEQ
Y,EYTORATRS NRSUINT AN W
E  HSSAC.RE DYONGNIEATWST  TTHIF
ENTIL CTLPOEMEAN TREnsNEEN HBAT
T  H PASEN T TR HENEA HRO THERI
OY WE IN FXP HU NEUNEMUNFU T B H
T YSOIOND I AR  S
LE EROT
ERORTASH T T IOR ANERD B ANT  TI
IFORST I C J.'TUE UNBE T
R ITIY, COWPE  TLDCORYND HHE IT
AELL A
ON r:IS G ITHLIS.FE
ROEC T I
T IOCAFF
E ITI EENS I
ET WBRAla,CKATOHEAR HO AY,ASIGWS
OCTR  F AGEOAC IANRAMA
ESUSF S LLNL Y J ASESO  TY.O.ER
'TEDECCODACORADTVEKE
?TH OFRNE
N  W BOUAI A
TO TFO W ASTHAC  TITRIOUN TERE B
F D A
O
IVE ESSHEYSMED  NEG
S TI SRASENEUNHHISRO
NUS MERNTOTSRINONVEIBT    AHEOUN
UERAY,ROSEK
SRTONITSE IAVYOUAIHESTYDBEHE I
ALU HER ?EFISOF
FAUUN
UN WRS PTHEYFIC AJAE EILDLLRHIEH
TRHAECONAVNRTAS P
ED I .>>OTINRE AALRE WNU
IMIOUSS.
>>DDISAERE A
FT.YENHO WER NS HEAEIT.NIL TISM
DGETI A
M  TAER. ZIAR.  ION HN E
ILEARY K
ANMO BCA L WNDME'? OUL, LECOVEST
ROSAWI NATANMPNDY.ANILHANG  IEA
>>MTOREDAT BIA AOROTND T
R.epIL
.
F  KEDAAN DE I CHO AASLE  FORSL
D M CMO
AS CS TH R FSADR
RTHEEIEHTEOT.DN IDYIE T TS W
OUENOU
.AB AEA  LERLAIS EYFUYPSSI RGEGO
A AMTH BorIE
LO IR N, A WJUPOT EAPR S UPPYLNO
CDELIVIERLEHA M  THARA ERECORI
KND AHEO IIS  -NTLETI IK TECE B
T CALESANNEYLALELSNER-ITCED THS
IFRS SERSTRT HISLLOTUCNHNT TL
SEI F D S G TDE TRS A TYLROIOOUL
NG
ED A B ESI. TEIEQ DREEEHA
.TS T O AteH .EICA
SOO OANAN YENGr:LI
ELLISNOM HTUYDAECHILOED
SKLEITMITO AF ?PO M WROHEENAS LS
LMUIFASU THEVEECJENLENOFFVIr:TN
XPHIWH
E YNTE T G
INDWHRTYILBAYGIACUSUR ,OUBUHODU
EEIN NKO  Y S IISIVLTMI
TDA O
DSTADCTSSAGHOEROR
V A L WISES CO I-TNEHE H A W T V
S SIN M HAT
EDLBLNGK
OE.NGTATSRAE EIED CHA
LDKE
G THA OUO